That's why we have talked about
some of the uses of metacognition.
We can use it to fix errors in
knowledge or reasoning or learning.
We can use it to fix gaps in knowledge,
reasoning, or learning.
We can use it for strategy integration.
One that we have not yet
talked about is what is the processes
that metacognition uses?
What is it's strategy?
Well, metacognition can use these
same kinds of reasoning processes
that is the surface reasoning goal.
That is, case-based reasoning is
a potential strategy for metacognition.
Constraint propagation is a potential
strategy for metacognition, and so on.
Let us take an example, supposedly if
metacognition comes across a problem and
it must select among these strategies.
Metacognition might ask itself,
what strategy did I pick the last
time I came across a similar problem?
This is case-based
reasoning at a meta level.
To complete this example, metacognition
might say the last time I used
constraint propagation as a technique
with this particular problem,
this time I'll use constraint
propagation again.
As another example,
given a second problem,
metacognition may use planning to set up
a plan for using the various strategies,
thinking of each of
the strategies as an operator.
>> As a third example, metacognition
might get a new problem and decide to
use every single method at it's disposal
to generate a possible solution.
It then might have some heuristics
to test each one of those possible
solutions and
figure out which one is best.
So then it's using Generate & Test to
select between it's multiple strategies.
>> To summarize this part then,
metacognition can use the same reasoning
strategies that we have been
studying at the deliberative level.